it's interesting though that at this
time at least in human history there
seems to be a gap between the tools of
science
and uh the subjective experience that
people report like you're talking about
with telepathy and
it seems like
we're not quite there no I think that
there is no gap between the tools of
science and telepathy either it's there
it's not and it's an empirical question
and if it's there we should be able to
detect it in a lab so why is there not a
lot of Michael Evans walking around I I
don't think that Michael 11 is uh
specifically focused on telepathy very
much he is focused on self-organization
in living organisms and in brains both
as a paradigm for development and
there's a paradigm for information
processing and when you think about how
organization processing works on
organisms there is first of all radical
locality which means everything is
decided locally from the perspective of
an individual cell the individual cells
the agent and the other one is coherence
basically there needs to be some
Criterion that determines how these
cells are interacting in such a way that
order emerges on the next level of
structure and this principle of
coherence of
imposing constraints that are not
validated by the individual parts and
lead to coherent structure to basically
Transcendent the agency where you form
an agent on the next level of
organization is crucial in this
perspective it's so cool that radical
locality
leads to the emergence of complexity at
the higher layers and I think what Mike
Levin is looking at is is nothing that
is outside of the realm of Science in
any way it's just that he is a
paradigmatic thinker who developed his
own Paradigm and most of the numerous
scientists are using a different
Paradigm at this point and this often
happens in science that a field is has a
few paradigms in which people try to
understand reality and build Concepts
and make experiments you're kind of one
of those type of paradigmatic thinkers